اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
البنتاجون يعتزموا تمديد نشر الاف الجنود
الامريكيين في رومانيا وبولندا تلوح
باعلامي تحالف اصغر لتسليم دبابات حديثه
لاوكرانيا اذا لم يكن هناك اتفاقا بشان
دبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه هذا هو حذرت
روسيا من اجراءات انتقاميه في حال تزويد
اوكرانيا باسلحه
من حكومته بناء على قرار المحكمه
الاسرائيليه العليا بعدم امكانيه استمراره
في منصبه الوزاري بسبب ادانته سابقا
بتهمتي لاحتيال والسرقه من جهه انتقد
حكومه نتنياهو وقال انها اشبه بحلبه السرك
بوركينا فاسو تطلب انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
من اراضيها في غضونها على خلفيه توتر
وتصاعد بين البلدين في حين اكدت مصادر
قريبه من الحكومه ان القرار يتعلق
باتفاقات التعاون العسكري وليس قطعا
للعلاقات مع باريس العمله الايرانيه تواصل
تراجعها وتسجل ادنى مستوى لها على الاطلاق
مقابل الدولار اذا فقد الريال نحو 30% من
قيمته منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في البلاد في
شهر سبتمبر اي دوله الماضي
الى اللقاء